(upbeat funky music plays)
- Strongly agree.
- Strongly disagree.
- Somewhat agree.
- Somewhat disagree.
- I would agree.
- [Both] Disagree.
- [Announcer] We brought together six exes
who all dated this guy.
- Hey, I'm Josh.
(bell dings)
- And had them rank each other
based on how good they
think they were in bed.
- First, we started with feet pics.
- I had a pretty bad experience.
- Us two.
- [Announcer] Then we had
their ex rearrange them
by how good they actually were.
This is Ranking.
(mischievous music plays)
- Hey, I'm Josh.
(bell rings)
- Hi, I'm Bryan. Josh's ex.
- I'm Sam.
- I'm Samantha.
- I'm April.
- I'm Jessly. I'm Josh's ex.
- I'm Antonio.
- [Announcer] How do you guys feel
like Josh is gonna rank you guys?
- I think Josh is gonna be
a little bit more, like,
an emotional heart, like connection.
- I think Josh is like based
on how much fun he has.
- Me personally, I have a high ego.
So, I feel like not only
will he keep my ego up
but he'll also explain the
great memories that him
and I had.
- [Announcer] So, next steps is that
I'm going to take Josh out of here.
- Bye!
- Bye Josh.
- Goodbye Josh.
- I go this way.
- Go, go.
- Goodbye.
- I'm scared.
We all seen each other naked
so it's like that's
what's weird about this.
(mischievous music plays)
- Should we talk about
how we first met Josh?
- Oh yeah.
- I'm a gardener
and I would always see Josh walk by
when I was outside in the front yard.
- I met him at my job.
I worked at Dunkin Donuts
and he'd just come in a lot
and then I would just see him
more frequently coming in.
And then we just started
talking more and more.
- I've known him for a long time too.
We went to school together.
We were each other's firsts.
- We both like were at the same concert
and then my ride
unfortunately bailed on me
and Josh was like, "Oh hey,
like, I can take you home."
Yeah, and then we just
continued talking after that.
- One day while being in
the same class as Josh
we were partnered up together
and through that and Josh's personality
just kinda like swept me off my feet.
With him I thought I officially
could collar my first friend
until I found out that he cheated on me.
(record scratches)
I gave him a second
chance of being my friend
because of the connections that we had.
Having to relive that I would
like to be the bigger man
and I would like to be friends with him.
- I think based off what we think
or how good we thought it was
that's how we can tell what Josh thought,
maybe?
- Yeah.
- So, like who actually
had a good experience or-
That sounds bad.
(all laughing)
- Okay.
- But who had good experiences with Josh?
- Okay, I don't think I had
like the best experience
but I don't think, like, it was,
had like the worst experience.
Like, I have pretty good memories.
- Were we all off and on with him?
- I was off and on with him.
- What?
- Were you guys off
and on with him?
- I wasn't.
- Or was it just like one
continuous time and then done?
- I wasn't off and on.
- Josh was just playing, man.
- Okay, so who thinks they had, like,
the worst experience with Josh?
- I had a pretty bad experience.
- [April] Okay.
- Us two. The hell?
(Samantha and April giggling)
- Okay, do you guys wanna like compare
so that we know like...
- With me, this dude, every
time we would, you know,
he would be tensed up.
- He would be what?
- He's so stiff.
He's so stiff. (group laughing)
He's, no, Josh is like-
- Is it just bad for everyone?
(group laughing)
Is tense worse than crying?
- He cried?!
- Josh cried.
- No way, man.
- It was my first time with a guy
'cause I was just, I was exploring things.
He cried afterwards.
(April giggles)
- With our relationship.
We went, we converted our
relationship into (mumbles).
We went that, we did that
for like a couple months.
I hope this isn't too personal
but first we started with feet
pics (camera shutter clicks)
and then...
- People who do like
send feet pics, like...
- They're better at sex.
- That's enjoy. Yeah.
- Statistically speaking,
- Also-
- People who send feet
pics are better at sex.
- You, you do research on that?
- I think I should go lower.
I think I wanna switch with you.
- Yeah.
- Okay.
- I'd back you up with me too.
The best way to collectively,
collectively gauge
where we're at
is how many bad
experiences we had with him
(Bryan hums)
and then whoever has the most,
obviously, is in the last.
- I'm like a really awkward person.
Like, I laugh (stammers)
when I'm in uncomfortable
situations, you know?
And there was like a time, like,
after we had sex and it
was just like silence
and I just started laughing
and I felt so bad about it.
I feel like that kind of ruined it.
So, maybe I wanna switch it to you.
Like it was just the awkward...
- I feel like I definitely helped Josh
explore his sexual journey.
Generally, he had a good time
so I would put myself higher.
- Okay, do you wanna switch with...
- Yeah.
- Where do you wanna go?
- I'll go next to Pablo
'cause-
- Oh wow. Okay.
- I'll push you guys down.
- You were, just saying that.
- I'm confident.
- Dude, you just said that, like,
you had like, it was-
- [Sam] Okay.
- Yeah, you said you were the worst one.
- So, it was bad sometimes,
but it was good other times.
- I do see myself at the top because-
- Are you thinking of yoursel-
Just you, yourself at the top
or your relationship with Josh at the top?
- I feel like you're just
thinking of you (Pablo stutters)
because you have a-
- I'm including both.
Like, how I said I do have a high ego
but I am including both just to be sure.
- But you have to think
about what Josh thinks
and if he cheated on you...
- Like, did he really
value that relationship?
I think that part was
really confusing to me.
He still thought of his
relationship with Josh
so, like, high.
- It was pretty difficult
to communicate with Josh.
Like, I try to. It'd
just be kind of awkward.
Like, he'd just like brush it aside
and it was like hard to be vulnerable.
- I completely disagree with that
because with the conversations
that him and I had
were pretty sentimental.
Which was another reason why
I gave Josh a second an
opportunity of him being my friend.
- It feels like difficult
to like hear that
because like...
(beep) Okay, sorry.
Like, I tried really hard
and then just, like,
to hear that he was like
that with other people.
I had a whole picture painted of Josh.
I was like pretty overwhelmed
and I even was starting
to get, like, teary-eyed
talking about it.
- Do you think this is
what Josh would rank us?
- I think we're okay
where we're standing then.
- Yeah, I think.
- Yeah.
- [Announcer] You're locking it in?
(mischievous music plays)
- Wow.
Oh, it's interesting order.
So, first of all,
I think me and you both know,
like, what I'm gonna do here.
Sam can like, can you come to the back?
You gotta switch it back.
- Okay.
I don't know if, like,
when you were in here talking to them,
you explained like...
- I told them we had
a nuanced relationship
and that sometimes it
was better than others.
- [Announcer] Did you have an
idea of what you were gonna do
when you came in here?
- This was the only idea I had so far,
kinda of, so... (group laughing)
- I don't need to say anything
more. It was terrible.
- I'm gonna have April, like,
go to the front a little bit
so I can think about that.
- Where?
- Maybe next Pablo,
or Antonio, whatever name you wanna use.
I'm gonna have Pablo come
down like right here.
Okay, I'm gonna have
you two switch places.
- Us too?
- [Josh] Yeah. Jessly,
you know our whole thing?
- Yeah.
- We were like...
Well like...
- See he can't give me an, oh my god.
- It's kind of weird when
it comes to us two, like...
- No, 'cause I'm kind of-
No, 'cause-
Okay.
- We were just...
Yeah.
- You can't use
- Personally-
- No, no, no, no.
You still can't communi-
No, no, that's my thing. Okay.
You still can't communicate
and that's so like annoying.
Of course I'm gonna have a big reaction
because 'til this day he's
still not communicating with me.
I felt like we got nowhere.
- There was hostility. (laughs)
They have every right to,
like, be mad at me I guess.
Okay, I'm gonna switch Pablo and Bryan.
- Whoa.
- [April] Okay.
- That's...
- I think you're a good person, right?
It's just sometimes things
don't always work out
with people.
Bryan's pretty good.
Like, I can't like show
you but that'd be...
(group giggling)
That'd be bad.
- I guess you liked me or you liked it?
- It.
- It?
- I think I might switch you two actually.
- Me and Pablo?
- Yeah.
- Thank you.
- Dang.
- No, you're gonna make
Pablo have a big head again.
- April? We know. I don't even
have to move you that much.
Like, you were already up
there I think when we started.
I don't know if they-
Did you tell them like
our virginity stuff?
(group laughs)
That was a long story.
- I didn't go into details.
I just said we were each other's firsts.
- So, that's why I kind
of, like, rank her more.
I don't know. I know that's unfair.
It's just, like, that's
how I think about things.
I think I'm gonna keep
Sam definitely right here.
- You haven't explained it.
I mean it was bad.
- [April] Check up on Sam after this.
- I told everyone that
it was my first time.
- It wasn't mine.
Yeah, maybe switch Bryan
and Pablo actually.
- Thank you.
- [Josh] Then this is good.
- [Samantha] Why are you
moving them?
- [Josh] This is good.
This is good.
- Are you sure?
- Yeah, like-
- You cheated on Pablo.
- Okay, so it is kind of like,
I do feel bad though
but at the same time, like,
it wasn't my fault.
- Yeah, you should.
- I liked-
- It wasn't your fault
that you cheated?
What?
- We don't have to get
into that like that.
You guys can stay there.
Like, that's a long story.
But personally I think
this is good for me.
Like, I don't wanna move anything.
This is a good learning lesson.
Being in a room with people we've all-
Well, I've seen you guys
naked. (record scratches)
You guys haven't seen each other
naked.
- Stop.
- Okay, Josh.
- But I think this is a good
learning lesson here, like...
- I think it taught us
that you are kind of like
a big red flag, honestly.
- Oh.
Wait, really?
- [All] Yeah.
- [April] You're just like-
- [Antonio] Yes.
- Like, you have
a lot of things you need to work on.
- I like her. I feel like
she did what I couldn't do.
- Yeah.
- You really do.
- Like a lot.
- That's okay.
- What made you think that?
- Maybe we don't cheat on people.
Maybe learn how to
communicate your feelings.
- [Announcer] What did
this experience teach you?
- I'm really all over the place
and I need to like fix that.
Like, if someone's gonna enter my life,
I need to make sure everything's
got a strong foundation.
'Cause personally, I made some
mistakes and they did too.
I should change things, obviously.
I need to change some things.
Am I still allowed to move people?
- [Announcer] I'm gonna
give you two minutes
to lock this in.
- Okay, I'm gonna switch you two again.
- Again?
- Yeah, I'm sorry.
- Dang.
- Personally, the things I'm into,
these people play into them more, like,
submissiveness, I guess, like...
I don't know, aggressiveness
comes into play kind of.
I don't really wanna dive into that.
Like, those are like
things people like in bed.
They play into that role
more than you guys I guess.
- Oh, yeah.
Yeah, I get that.
- Yeah.
- Now, I'm good with this now.
(upbeat music plays)
- [Announcer] Josh, there
is a little extra surprise.
I asked all of your exes to rank you
on a scale of 1 to 10.
- You (laughs)
Okay?
- [Announcer] Sam gave you a two.
- Oh, wow. Really?
- [Announcer] Jessly gave you a six.
- All right, that's good I
guess. I'm fine with that.
- He's a two.
- [Announcer] Samantha gave you a six.
Pablo gave you a 6.5.
- Oh, really?
- [Announcer] Bryan gave you a seven.
April gave you a six.
- Yeah, there's like a
thing going on there.
- [Ex] Average.
- [Ex] Obviously, yeah.
- [Ex] Improves though. Yeah.
- [Announcer] How do you feel
now that they've given you a ranking?
- I mean, ranking them was fun.
Like, I know how it feels
now being in their shoes.
That kind of sucked.
- Me and Josh, we grew together
and it's important to
learn from the mistakes,
not just criticize them.
If you're emotionally immature
or if you were not in the best
place when you're together,
take that and make yourself better.
- I still like you Josh, even
though you gave me a two.
I'm mad at you though.